now this is near where Rex Patchett was
struck by a vehicle after police say it
lost control it happened right in front
of his middle school and for his father
Jason Patchett revisiting this area is
traumatic
it's traumatizing it's hard it's
definitely very difficult for for me for
my wife for my children we have to drive
I mean we just live up the street so we
drive past every day multiple times a
day this was the last photo taken of Rex
an hour before he was tragically killed
he was at a friend's house and was
riding his scooter back home on the
sidewalk for any of the family to have
the experience what we experienced that
night
is something that I just cannot allow to
happen again the city of Henderson tells
me since the incident happened on March
7th a traffic study has been conducted
for this neighborhood Public Works is in
the process of adding a rapid flashing
pedestrian Beacon near Skyline and
Paradise Hills to enhance safety Jason
patches says he doesn't know if that is
enough I don't know what the solution is
but there's got to be something done
because it continues to happen my son
was killed as a result of someone you
know breaking the law Henderson police
arrested Jose marvolejo police say the
21 year old driver lost control of his
car they don't believe he was impaired
but he was speeding the best I can do
for justice for my son is to stand up
for him and stand up for every other
child that lives in this neighborhood
because this is about child safety
Jason says once the court case ends it
will close one chapter in his family's
healing Journey reporting live in
Henderson Joshua paguero eight news now